hand Independence the capacity to
perform an action with one hand and a
different one with the other it's an
integral part of how we perform
transitions with POI but even more
important than that if you struggled
with getting your non-dominant hand to
catch up with the skills of your
dominant hand you need this skill too
and I've got a workout to help you out
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of Po spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and in this video I'm going to give you
my five favorite beginner exercises for
developing hand Independence but before
we dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys pyrro Tera light toys
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- business friend of
the channel Becca beckon thank you so
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission so clearly there are lots
of exercises that can help us develop
hand Independence but in this workout
what I wanted to focus on are skills
that may not necessarily be skills that
you learned as a beginner but skills
that I believe everybody should learn at
as beginners things that when you become
fluent with them are going to help you
out with a lot of beginner skills and
that really help you get down a lot of
those beginner techniques so if you want
to see me repeat this with say some
intermediate or advanced level exercises
please leave me a comment and let me
know and without further Ado we're going
to start this exercise off with arguably
the most basic form of hand Independence
that you can find in poy namely being
able to adjust your timing
most of us when we first start off
spinning poi will'll be doing it either
in together Time same direction or we
will be performing together opposites or
butterfly the reason for this is pretty
simple if our hands are moving up and
down at the same time we don't have to
think that much about their actions
independently as opposed to split time
where we're having to calibrate each
movement in relation to the other which
is why split time is essential for us to
drill in a whole bunch of different
positions I'll show you what I mean
we're going to go ahead and start off
spinning the POI together Time same
direction at our sides and wheel plane
we want to get in 10 beats like this and
then when we want to switch to split
Time same direction going forwards in
wheel plane we then want to go ahead and
switch to spinning reverse in together
Time same direction in wheel plane and
then split Time same direction in wheel
plane we want to get in 10 reps in each
of these spots next we want to perform
this in wall plane here spinning our poy
clockwise in together same and then
split Time same direction in wall plane
want to change direction to
counterclockwise spin the poy 10 times
in wall plane in uh counterclockwise and
then switch to split Time same direction
we're going to do the same thing in
Split time opposites then so go ahead
and get your right hand spinning reverse
your left hand spinning forwards and
we're going to start in together
opposites here get in 10 beats and then
switch to split time
opposites we're going to do the same
thing with the PO going the opposite
directions so right hand goes forward
left hand goes reverse again start in
together times so they're coming up and
going down at the same time for 10 beats
and then switch to split
time lastly we want to switch over into
wall plane so go ahead and give me a
butterfly in wall plane here going
Inward and then a split time butterfly
each of these you want to get in 10
beats on and then switch to a reverse
butterfly and a reverse split time
butterfly and that's the exercise next
up we're going to drill some hand
Independence in that other most
important POI concept when we're
starting off that's right
planes so this one is going to be
essential for another po exercise on
this list and it involves keeping the
two Po in slightly different planes we
know that we have wheel plane out on the
sides of our bodies but in between our
arms here we also have buzzsaw plane now
for this one you might want to shorten
up your PO just a little bit so you've
got easier access to that buzs saww
plane but essentially what we're going
to do is we're going to experiment with
having one poy off in wheel plane and
the other Po in buzzsaw plane and we're
going to keep them spinning together I'm
going to start this off in together same
going forwards with my right hand in
buzs saww and my left hand out in wheel
I'm going to switch off and I'm going to
have my left hand spin in buzs saww
plane and my right hand spin in wheel
plane I'm going to go ahead and learn
this in all the other timing Direction
and Direction modes as well so I'm going
to go ahead and get the PO spinning
reverse and I'm going to put that right
hand in buzs Saw plane while my left
hand is out in wheel plane and then I'm
going to switch things up and have my
left hand spinning and buzs saww plane
my right hand out in wheel plane and
then I'm going to go ahead and switch
into together opposites and start with
my right hand going forward my left hand
going reverse once again I'm going to
stick my right hand into the buzs saww
plane and keep them both spinning in
together opposites 10 beats and then I'm
going to switch things up and have my
left hand spinning in buzzsaw plane like
so I'm going to go ahead and switch
directions on this one so I've got my
right hand going reverse my left hand
going forwards put put the right hand in
between my arms and buz saw plane while
my left hand is out in wheel for 10
beats and then switch up to having my
left hand spinning in buz Saw plane for
10 beats next I'm going to switch to
split Time same direction put my right
hand into buz saw plane keep it going
for 10 beats going forwards and then
switch up to having my left hand
spinning forwards in Split Time same
direction in buz saww plane going to
switch to reverse and again going to
have my right hand spinning and Buzz
saww plane for 10 beats then my left
hand spinning and buzs saww for 10 beats
now I'm going to switch into split time
opposites so I'm going to go ahead and
get my right hand spinning forward my
left reverse and keep this timing up
with my right hand in between my arms
and then with my left hand in between my
arms I switch things up my right hand
reverse my left hand forward and once
again 10 be beats with my right hand in
buzs saww keeping the timing and then 10
beats with my left hand in buzs saww
keeping the timing if you can get all
those you've got the exercise down good
job next up we're going to practice
switching back and forth between these
timing and Direction modes with an
exercise specifically centered around
pendulums all right so for this exercise
I want you to start in a butterfly and I
want you to go ahead and practice
performing pendulum with just one hand
so in this case I'm going to choose my
right and what I want to do is I want to
perform in pendulum out with my right
come back around with both of my poise
spinning in together same clockwise and
then I'm going to perform another
pendulum with my right going underneath
my left and bring it back around to a
butterfly again I perform a pendulum out
with my right and then across with my
right and that takes me through both
together same as well as together
opposites uh really important if you are
working on getting just one hand to do
the pendulum and not the other one uh
something that will really frequently
happen is you might perform the pendulum
with both hands or you might wind up
performing it with neither hands aim
towards performing the pendulum with
both hands and at the last minute take
the hand that's supposed to keep moving
and give it a little bit of a kick to
keep on spinning then you can work with
what the other hand is doing so again we
want to do pendulum out pendulum back
back and return to our butterfly then we
want to do the same thing with the left
hand pendulum out pendulum back back to
the butterfly switch off hands here
right under and back left under and back
back and forth at least 10 times cool
next up what I think is one of the most
important ingredients for any po spinner
to drill when they're first starting off
namely we're going to be playing around
with Tic Tacs
so Tic Tacs are This Plane bending
action where we're taking the PO back
and forth across our body but
fundamentally keeping it spinning the
Same Direction the entire time now we
want to be able to perform a Tic Tac
with only one hand and not the other we
start this off by having the Poise
spinning forwards at our sides and I'm
going to take my right hand and I'm
going to begin performing Tic Tacs back
and forth passing the PO in between my
arms in buz saww plane and then back to
own native side I'm going to do 10 reps
of this and then 10 reps of the same
action with my left
hand as with several other exercises on
this list this is an exercise that we
probably want to perform in all timing
and Direction modes and in all
directions so next up I'm going to get
the pois spinning reverse in together
Time same direction and repeat this
exercise with just my right hand
performing the Tic Tac and then with
just my left hand performing the Tic Tac
next up we're going to do the same thing
in together opposites so I'm going to
start with my right hand going forward
my left hand going reverse once again my
right hand is going to pass between buz
saww plane and then back out to the side
and then I'm going to have my left hand
pass into buz saww plane and then back
out to the side going to do 10 reps of
this with each hand then I'm going to
switch directions right hand reverse
left hand forward and once again right
hand goes
between for 10 reps
and then left hand goes between for 10
reps and then I'm going to play around
with my split timings starting with
split Time same direction again right
hand is going to perform the Tic Tacs
first going back and forth between Buzz
saw plane and back out to wheel plane
and then I'm going to let my left hand
perform the same action going in and out
in and out and I'm going to do the same
thing in Reverse right hand gets 10 reps
going in between and then back out
working very hard to keep my timing here
and then my left hand is going to work
on going in between and then back out
like so next up I'm going to play around
in uh split time opposites so I'm going
to start off with my right hand forward
my left hand reverse and once again I'm
going to work on performing 10 Tic Tacs
with my right hand and not my left hand
and then perform tin Tic Tacs with my
left hand and not my right hand i'm then
going to switch directions right hand
reverse left forward again 10 reps with
my right hand going in between my arms
and then 10 reps with my left hand going
in between my
arms you get all that down you've got
this exercise congratulations all right
so for our final exercise on this list
we're going to play around with the
thing that I know a bunch of people have
been waiting for since I first mentioned
Transitions and that is pois
stalls so this exercise is going to feel
an awful lot like our pendulum's
exercise uh namely we're going to be
switching back and forth between
together opposite and together same once
again we're just going to be using
stalls to get back and forth between
these two positions so this time around
I'm going to be using bottom stalls
which are an awful lot like pendulums
and then down stalls where I point the
POI down towards the floor and then pull
them back out in the opposite direction
just like we did with pendulums it might
be helpful to warm up on this one by
having the hand that is performing the
stall do so and focus on keeping that
hand in pois still while the other hand
is moving and then bring the poy back in
the direction that you prefer you can do
this both by letting the bottom stall
for lack of a better term stall out and
also by performing the down stall and
just hanging out there for a second
getting used to the left hand still
spinning the POI while the right hand is
stalled down before coming back into a
butterfly once again you want to do this
with each hand so we're going to have
the right hand do a bottom
stall and then a down stall 10 times and
then we're going to have the left hand
do a bottom stall and then a down stall
10 times we're going to get used to
being able to perform these transitions
by performing stalls only one hand at a
time and if you can get that down
congratulations you've gotten the whole
workout done hey friend are you hungry
for even more po exercises after all of
this well I've got a tip for you and
it's called the flow Circle the flow
circle is a weekly exclusive lesson
that's available only to my patreon
supporters each week you'll get access
to a brand new lesson that'll help you
get down the latest POI tricks
techniques and POI Theory to sign up
head on over to
patreon.com dfactor PO did you get
anything out of this video please make
sure to like share comment and subscribe
to help other people find it and to help
my channel grow
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you you all rock
and if you're not currently a supporter
but you'd like to become one you can
always do that by heading on over to
patreon and signing up at
patreon.com drexfactor po where you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards but even better than that you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
po spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you and if you'd like to check
out my 15-minute beginner po workout I
will go ahead and leave a link to that
up on screen as well as down in the
description thank you so much for
watching I hope this video was helpful
and I hope to see you out there flowing
thanks so much and have a good one take
care now peace